[Music]
hello Iran's president Ibrahim raisi has
landed in the Syrian Capital Damascus on
the first visit by an Iranian leader
since the War Began in 2011. Iran and
Russia have backed president Bashar
al-assad with economic and Military
Support which helped him to regain
control of most of the country in a TV
interview president raisi said he is
ready to cooperate with Syria in
rebuilding the nation we have two
correspondents keeping track of this
Landmark visit by the Iranian leader
zenokudur is a neighboring Lebanon but
first we go to dorsan Jabari in Tehran
so tell us about the timing of this
dorsa and why the president is there now
well Doreen the Iranian president is
making what many here are calling
historic visit because it's the first
time in 13 years that an Iranian
president has visited uh Syria a country
which is very close to Iran in terms of
politically and economic uh ties Ibrahim
racy has decided to make this trip at
the invitation that was extended to him
by Bashar al-assad who was in Iran last
year feeling clearly that this is the
right time given that the Syrian
president has managed to secure his
position in his country Following over a
decade of conflict inside Syria Ibrahim
races being accompanied by a number of
his ministers including the defense
minister the foreign minister the
economy Minister and the oil Minister
all with the aim of uh first improving
what they call the access of resistance
meaning providing support to Syria to be
able to combat what they believe to be
enemy powers
launching attacks inside Syria namely
Israel and Iran has certainly been on
the receiving end of those attacks a
number of revolutionary guard officials
have been killed in Syria over the past
decade and the last figure we have as of
2016 that was over 2 000 but many
believe that figured to be much higher
now the Iranian president also has a
number of members from the private
sector alongside him trying to seal some
deals in AIM with the aim of rebuilding
Syria and that will be one of the main
topics of discussion as well the
Reconstruction of the country after the
devastating War okay thank you so much
dorsa for that update from Tehran well
now bring in xenover joining us from the
north of Lebanon so Syria and Iran very
strategic allies and the relationship
goes back decades what is Syria hoping
to get out of this visit
well at the end of the day this is Iran
projecting its power its influence this
is clearly a political message because
of the timing against the backdrop of
Arab states re-engaging with the Syrian
president Bashar al-assad who has been
largely isolated for more than a decade
we saw Arab foreign ministers land in
Damascus in in recent weeks we saw
meetings in Jeddah in Amman talking
about the possibility of reintegrating
Syria into the Arab League now no doubt
this worries Iran so the message from
Iran is we are a close Ally of Damascus
we will remain a close Ally of Damascus
and this Alliance will not come at the
expense of any re-engagement because
during the last meeting in Amman on
Monday our foreign ministers laid out
some sort of an initiative if you like a
road map in order for Syria to re-engage
with the Arab world and what we
understand is that the Arab world is
concerned about about the presence of of
armed groups linked to Iran they are
worried about Iran's influence so the
message raisy is giving is that we are
here to stay at the end of the day he
talks about the Strategic relationship
for Iran Syria is very strategic its
geographic location gives it another
front against Israel its allies here in
Lebanon are are on the border with
Israel the same thing in Syria the same
thing in Gaza so in many ways it gives
Iran an upper hand and Syria lies along
that land Corridor between Tehran and
Beirut a supply line which really gives
Iran its Regional reach its Regional
influence so politics is now at play
throughout the years we've seen
high-ranking military officials from
Iran land in Damascus today it's the
president so this is clearly about
politics